hallo leute ich ist wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute ist mal wieder eine
ganz besondere folge denn am 24.9 sind
in deutschland bundestagswahl am sonntag
gewählt wenn ihr dürft macht ist und zu
diesem anlass möchte ich mit euch
herausfinden wie schmeckt deutschland
knackig wie wiener herzhaft wie
frankfurter und zart wie banken
durchschnittlich jetzt so ein glas mit
wurst holen sollen und dann wäre die
frage auch schon beantwortet es ist eine
wirklich schwierige aufgabe
herauszufinden wie deutschland
eigentlich schmeckt und da habe ich mein
gehirn eingeschaltet und dachte mir so
was ist so richtig typisch deutsch
waffeln und jetzt denkt ihr gemacht film
ja machen überlegt doch mal was gibt es
auf jeder geburtstagsparty muffins was
bringt man in die schule mit wenn man
geburtstag hat marvin was ist auf meinem
t-shirt drauf nach filmen wie ameisen
sind nicht so ganz typisch deutsch aber
sie passen perfekt zu dem was machen
möchte also letzte aber bevor wir
anfangen möchte ich euch noch mal eine
coole pose zeigen
blumen und ich habe alles mit meinem
dicken hintern film und ja ich weiß mein
kopf sieht manchmal ziemlich groß aus
das liegt aber an meinem objektiv war
das ein weitwinkelobjektiv ist sieht
mein kopf hat wenn ich nach vorne komme
größeres nach hinten kleiner dafür hat
sich nicht viel
auf jeden fall checkt ihres abnormalen
großen courts bin zwar sehr schlauen
hatten großen kopf aber nicht
überdimensional groß ja gut dann haben
wir das jetzt geklärt und jetzt geht's
wirklich los
let's make deutsche waffen für unsere
deutschen muffins brauchen wir 80 gramm
deutsche butter drei deutsche eier
deutsche milch deutsches mail und
natürlich deutschen zucker und vergesst
nicht dass deutsche backpulver zuerst
geben wir die deutsche mutter in eine
rührschüssel darauf folgen 140 gramm
deutscher zucker und jetzt kommen die
deutschen eier einhändig und nur dran
und die drei zutaten miteinander
verrühren
ein
hallo
und freiheit
[Musik]
eine deutsche eier butter zucker
mischung durch gerührt ist dann nehmen
wir unser deutsches mail und tunis in
die schüssel hinz und brüderlich wie wir
sind kommt noch eine halbe packung
backpulver dazu sie folgt dem i und
weiter sie alles so viel spaß macht
kommt die deutsche milch gleich
hinterher
und jetzt noch einmal verdienen
[Applaus]
ofen vorheizen auf 180 grad und dann
habt ihr euren deutschen machen teig und
gebt die die macht von diesen schon mal
richtig lecker aus und deren bestimmt
auch richtig gut schmecken aber wisst
ihr was ich glaube deutschland kann auch
ein bisschen mehr das beste an
deutschland ist seine vielfalt und
deswegen nehme nicht nur deutsche
produkte wenn mir deutsche muffins
machen möchten nein wir nehmen alle
leckeren zutaten die es auf der ganzen
welt gibt wie zum beispiel sind jetzt
mal ehrlich könnt ihr euch weihnachten
ohne zins vorstellen und dabei ist es
nicht mal ein deutsches produkt und nie
würde jemand auf die idee kommen sind
aus der deutschen küche zu verband
genauso ist es mit vanille jeder
eisdiele gibt es preise und es ist super
beliebten dabei wechsel nicht mal in
deutschland und nun kommt für mich die
wichtigste zutat für gute deutschen
muffins schokolade wird aus der
kakaobohne gewonnen und ist auch nicht
aus deutschen und rein damit
und das verrühren wir jetzt noch mal
schön zusammen fertig und den teig geben
wir jetzt auch in unserer firma versteht
mich nicht falsch der erste teil wird
bestimmt auch sehr gut schmecken aber
der zweite tag hat einfach viel mehr
geschmacks liefern und durch die
schokostückchen verdi zweiten muffins
nicht automatisch zu schuhladen muffins
sondern zu muffins mit schokostückchen
von jetzt den ofen damit die machen sind
jetzt gebacken und abgekühlte damit wir
sie gut unterscheiden können kommt jetzt
die buttercreme obendrauf
jetzt kann man sie gut unterscheiden und
jetzt stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigste frage wie schmeckt
deutschland wir probieren erstmal den
blauen machen
[Musik]
okay ist ein solider machen also auch
sehr schön fluffig kündigt lecker so
schnell kann's gehen plötzlich habe ich
eine blaue zunge nimmt muss man echt
aufpassen
und jetzt kommt der zweite religion mit
der schokolade und der teig ist hier
auch super fluffig und blecker also
richtig gut nur hier schmeckt man
einfach viel mehr noch die schokolade
der zimt vanille das macht alles so ein
bisschen aufregender auch nicht sofort
beide machen schmecken mir echt gut bei
denen hier ist mir allerdings zu wenig
los ist es sofort ja langweilig halters
zeit ein süßer teig und hier ist einfach
durch die schokolade zimt vanille ist es
so man erlebt einfach mehr denn die
ganzen sinne werden hier einfach viel
mehr angeregt als dort das halt so
langweilig und ich muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen wenn ich auf einer party wäre und
es diesen muffin geben würde und ich
zimt vanille oder schokolade nicht mögen
würde würde ich niemals priesen machten
aus protest essen das wäre so bescheuert
einfach so langweiligen machen essen
weil wir eine zutat nicht gefällt ja
super er gibt dir absolut nichts
vielleicht ein paar mehr kilos auf der
waage aber das war's dann auch schon
hier hast du richtig ramba zamba das ist
richtig gut und die beiden sind sie vom
geschmack schon ähnlich weil sie das
gleiche grundrezept haben aber am ende
ist der bessere
darin bringt das ist so richtig gut
denkt dran leute am sonntag den 24 19
sind bundestagswahlen in deutschland
wenn ihr nicht wollt dass es nur noch
solche machen es auf partys gibt dann
geht wählen
nee so gut gut nie so gut ich hoffe ihr
könnt alle metaphern verstehen und bist
was ich euch sagen möchte also wenn euch
das video gefallen hat dann gibt einen
daumen nach oben das hilft mir gut
weiter und wenn ihr es teilen wollt dann
tut ist wenn ihr vielleicht freunde hat
die sich noch nicht sicher sind ob sie
wählen gehen möchten dann steht ihnen
dieses video und sagt wie willst du das
deutschland schmeckt dann geh wählen
damit das nicht so langweilig schmeckt
das ist nämlich durch vielfalt ist gut
und hier sind noch weitere videos ihr
könnt die anklicken und ich geh jetzt
noch nicht wählen weil es noch nicht
sonntag bis dann tschüss
also jetzt mal im ernst
geht wählen bitte es muffins ist noch
die kleinste sorge die wir dann haben
geht wählen